the Dutch language is the third most
widely spoken Germanic language after
English and German it's the official
language of the Netherlands and one of
the official languages of Belgium where
it's the native language of around 60%
of the population mainly in the northern
region of Flanders no not this Flanders
this Flanders in Dutch flandre the
history of the Netherlands and Belgium
are closely linked and they were under
the same rule at several points in their
history including the United Kingdom of
the Netherlands from 1815 to 1830 but
then the Belgian Revolution resulted in
the creation of the kingdom of Belgium
at first it had only one official
language French even though a large
percentage of its population was Flemish
in Dutch flams but Dutch eventually
became an official language alongside
French and Belgium and the only official
language in the region of Flanders
except for the Brussels Capital Region
which is bilingual